welcome to Udacity talks I think is our
eight so far my name is Sebastian I'd be
your moderator and this is all about
bringing unbelievably exceptional
warriors into a studio and pick their
brains about the future and life it's a
great honor today I have Padmasree
warrior it's a name with me she's one of
Forbes magazine's most powerful 100
women on the planet which means he
leaves about 4 billion other women
behind but he's also one of these iconic
people here in Silicon Valley having
worked for many years as Motorola worked
their way all the way up to CTO and
executive vice president at Cisco for a
long time
and now running a car company to the car
in the background here an electric car
company that has an office here in
Silicon Valley with about 350 people in
a partner company in China it's a it's
my honor to be here I enjoy talking
about technology but I love what you're
doing training the next generation
workforce for us so that we can tap into
the best rates in the world that's good
luckily this is not about me it's about
years so I have to ask you questions but
our form word usually is they asked a
few question up front and then I have a
lot of questions that our students
submitted and they're very curious to
get hundreds of those and I can't do a
hundred but I can do a few of them once
again
so you are born raised in India yes
that's right in India yes then what
brought you over I so I was born in
India I went to school in India I went
and did my undergraduate at Indian
Institute of Technology in New Delhi
good one and I studied Chemical
Engineering but my specialization was
more material so I was sort of always
interested in new materials and how new
materials are applied so I came to the
u.s. to go to graduate school I went to
Cornell University and that's where I
did I actually started my PhD but never
finished it I left after I got my
masters to do research in polymeric
materials and at the time I was
researching new materials for building
semiconductors in photoresist masking in
how you build
devices so I sort of branched off from
materials into more solid state and
semiconductor physics and after I
graduated started my career in Motorola
semiconductor as an engineer and I
always wanted to go back and teach but
once I started working you know I think
the excitement of building new products
and bringing those to market kept me
away from going back to finish my PhD
and teach I see
and then kind of I mean if I may ask for
the cliffnotes of your life here you
kind of made it from engineer to manager
to vice president to executive vice
president to CTO
which is a really big position and then
it come in a major public traded company
and the innovations was CEO like give me
the summary of what that yes so I would
say it's pretty boring I think I've had
a very boring career in the sense it's
very linear and very you know I think
maybe predictable I wish I had like been
in Hollywood for a year or done interior
design and then worked in engineering
you know I've been an engineer my whole
life my whole career I should say so
yeah I started as a line engineer in
semiconductors and then I became a chief
technology officer for Motorola
semiconductor I started to enjoy leading
people teams of engineers who built
things and and then I started to really
think about the business side of
technology so I went from being head of
engineering being chief technology
officer to running a business at
Motorola actually ran a lithium-ion
battery business at the time Motorola
was building mobile devices and cell
phones and we built our own batteries so
I ran that business for a while I which
had you know that back then it was
really all about operations how do you
build batteries that were cost-effective
with good margin so I learned the
business side of technology then I
became chief technology officer for
Motorola and we did the Razr I don't
know much we remember that yeah of
course if your phone yeah it was really
the first time a device had a name and a
personality yeah
that's right I actually started the
Android partnership with Google when I
was at Motorola then I left Motorola and
came to Cisco that's the chief
technology
officer ran worldwide engineering for
Cisco then I became chief strategy
officer and I was doing investments for
Cisco and working a lot with startups
and buying companies and bringing them
into Cisco then I kind of got the
startup bug and I think I was on the
other side as an investor for Cisco
investing in startups and I saw all the
passion these entrepreneurs had for
building companies so I left Cisco in
September of 2015 thinking I wanted to
do something on my own and I didn't
really know what I wanted to do I wanted
to go do something that would change in
industry I felt both that Motorola
licenses and at Cisco I participated in
changing the course of a company and
brought the companies into new spaces
when I left Cisco I was looking to go to
an industry and kind of shift the whole
industry and create a movement in a new
direction and so I was thinking me the
education actually or our transportation
those are the two articles I was
researching it sounds like very related
[Music]
is there any advice you would give
yourself back in India you know I think
the advice I would give myself is
perhaps when I was younger I was a
little bit too risk of word I mean not
it was not risk in the sense I think I
stayed in my comfort zone for longer
than I should have you know so the
advice I would give myself is to perhaps
branch out sooner than I did meaning I
was in engineering for a long time in my
career until very recently and it's it's
because I enjoy technical things and I
enjoy being pretty hands-on as an
engineer but I wish in as a younger
person I would have tried different
disciplines perhaps and got more
explosive doing it now I guess I am
doing it less fearful less restrained
today yes no I'm much more confident in
myself in what I do I'm still an
engineer at heart but building a company
requires lots of different skills I have
to say I'm really intrigued to have you
as a role model here in Silicon Valley I
think one of the things that's severely
lacks especially engineering instability
and something that you'd ask is really
important to us this was at you know a
student body in our employee base
because I think if you and whatever
you could actually be a much better
place so thanks for being a great role
model thank you that's very kind of you
so I have a few questions that our
students are from the way usually works
as I am the spokes are for our students
and they submit those and then every
mispronounce some of the student names
which is very common here the first ones
could be hard
Sparra Suvarna cover ii asked question
calculations for other accolades and
recognition is neo planning a
self-driving electric car yes we are
you're working on it right now yes are
you hiring yes yeah maybe though there
are fires
please come work for us what have skills
but have skills are you hiring right now
everything practically so I started last
year but just about a year ago we were
fifteen people now we have over 300
people we have offices in San Jose in
San Francisco we are hiring in
autonomous driving team everything from
machine learning controls firmware
hardware sensor fusion all different if
you like an engineer say the machine
learning or sensor fusion what are the
typical salary levels you'd be surprised
and because we're a start-up you know
there's a big wealth creation
opportunity for all yours so you give
everybody equity instinct a so students
listen up
and how far is your team progress when
you drive these days so we have a permit
in we have our nephew comes few startups
that I say have the permitted
tested in California they have testicles
we're developing the software and
testing it you know so we're making good
progress and we're in parallel building
a car as well so we are also working on
the vehicle engineering side we are
hiring even people interested in
building cars mechanical engineers and
electrical engineers working on
powertrain or batteries and sort of a
car team and we have a software team and
we're bringing those two words do it
good good good it sounds great honestly
topic very close to my heart
Nietzsche is asking question it's
obvious that autonomous vehicles are no
longer a future vision but more of a
current reality given that as a vehicle
manufacturer but you see the next
moonshot idea for the transportation
sector will be be am beyond south island
cars
electric cars that's a great great great
question so I think if you think of like
a moonshot meaning something that we all
dream would happen and perhaps would
take maybe years to happen right is how
do you actually shrink the time to
travel so for example when we had before
airplanes when we had ships it would
have taken as what from LA to Tokyo
would have taken as seven days or
something like that try to get from from
there now in air travel we've cut that
down to our 12 hours so let's say in a
half a day so could we do that kind of a
distance in maybe you know a few hours
12 well you know it today I travels 12
hours so could we do that in one hour
you know so that would be something
amazing to do so I know Ellen's working
on Hyperloop as part of that but what
other technologies could we think about
that cuts distance down and we've kind
of made that kind of progress in
communications right actually even when
I came to the US as a graduate student I
remember writing letters to my mom back
in India and you know it's probably now
that that whole art of letter writing is
is dead but imagine back then I would
mail a letter it would take three days
to go to India and if my mom replied it
would take three days for me to get a
reply back it was like seven days which
is fast by historians then but now it's
instantaneous right with whatsapp or
WeChat you just talk almost real-time so
what is it that we could do like that
for travel that would be moonshot so do
you think that supersonic travel will
come back then hopefully I don't know we
know it's possible right but I think
even you know if you say okay that's
farther out what would be maybe in the
next 10 to 12 years you know think
beyond self-driving car vehicle to
vehicle communication communication with
traffic lights you know would we have an
ecosystem where things actually are
talking to other things and making our
life easier and that's not so much of a
moonshot there is technology being
developed already for decades since it's
a right right but perhaps that you know
making that a real thing would be
something very exciting that seems to be
stuck a little bit as my impression to
be honest I think a lot of it has to do
with regulation
and standards right yeah yeah I mean so
much cell phone cost what fraction of
your lamp is broken seven cars but just
the other stuff the electric cars design
I mean we are all about self-driving
cars and so our focus is to build a
self-driving car that people will buy
we're not a rideshare company so we're
not developing cars for fleets you know
I'm I believe that cars are those
aspirational consumer products if you
will continue to be something that
people will want to own I think the
problem today and we've done a lot of
research on this we've asked people what
is it about your cars that you don't
like by and large people say they like
what they have in their cars but they
don't like what they do in their cars
they're stuck in traffic whenever I'd
say driving what do you think of
accident injury traffic pollution so if
we want to remove those problems and you
know Ike I said I grew up in Delhi New
Delhi yes and I just went back in
December to give a talk in New Delhi and
when I was a student there it was like
very very common that in the wintertime
the skies were blue and we would lie on
the lawns of the University and just
gaze at the skies and periodically do
our homework but now you know this time
when I went to Delhi
the skies were so polluted and they've
shut schools on regular basis that
children can go outside to play you know
so I think to me electric vehicles and
what we can do with self-driving
electric vehicles solves problems like
this for millions of people around the
world and so that's that's our
aspiration great Hoover Femi
is his name or her name asked a question
how do you think developing countries
especially Africa and I understand I
mean the Indian subcontinent countries
can catch up with some of the advanced
technologies what's your recommendation
for young smart people living in those
areas I think this could be one of those
things you know hey I worked in the
mobile communications world when
developing countries actually leapfrog
fixed internet and went directly to the
mobile internet right and both India and
China have done that and you know
there's a lot of innovation that happens
there a lot of places in India people
may not have internet connectivity but
they have mobile internet and they use
that for commerce for banking for
microloans
similar things could happen in mobility
right where people would skip
performance internal combustion engines
and go directly to electric vehicles as
the costs come down it'll be better for
the environment and I mean actually I
should say this we're a global startup
we have a sister company in China that's
working on v's for the China market and
I was just in India actually exploring
the potential for EVs and soft driving
cars in India actually if we can put us
out driving car in India I can probably
put it anywhere in the funny I studied a
little bit India and I think our rules
and I think they're there they might
like Western interpretation they relate
to the size of the vehicle you go first
if you're a bicyclist sequence exactly
but the point is that world is
continuing to urbanize right 2030 making
they said 60% of the world will live in
urban cities so people will continue to
flock to these cities that are gonna get
if you don't do anything about it
they'll get more crowded more congested
traffic will get worse and create more
pollution I think Jimmy one big part of
this answer is self-driving electric
vehicles where you don't need to live in
the center of the city to work there so
you don't believe in flying cars yet
I'm all for them I think I'm actually I
am a big believer in something that I
call autonomous economy I think will
shift to a lot of these things being
more autonomous delivery systems
you know flying cars drones self-driving
cars I think all of this will change
just like the mobile internet right you
know when we first moved from Smith's
cell phone to a smart phone
nobody really imagined it would change
so many other industries but it did and
you know and I was at on the other side
I was at Motorola at the time with a
[Music]
comes with the iPhone and they didn't
they're not just a phone company they
created the mobile Internet yeah so
similarly we want to be that company
that leads to this autonomous economy
nice fresh macaron how important was a
rapid innovative design engineering and
R&D capability of uk-based
motorsport valley company serves our
male or alicorn
now in helping you achieve the full
stunning potential of your flagship ep9
hypercar yeah so honor Mel was our
partner on the EP nine it is I mean to
me design is extremely important to me
really
I call this car three dardo I think it's
a sort of card reader on right which is
a autonomous electric vehicle helps us
redefine everything so we have a design
team in Munich that's that's our car
design team you know kudos to them I
think too although there are traditional
car designers they're totally rethinking
what the car of the future will be
so when today's cars are mostly
optimized for the driver and when you
take the driver of the out of the
equation you have to focus on the
interior design as much as you currently
focus on the exterior design so design
and styling actually have to change too
so design schools where car design is
one one of the biggest disciplines and
most design schools traditionally focus
a lot on the exterior design now have to
shift that focus and then partners like
rml who worked with us on EP 9 so people
ask me why did we build a supercar you
know it's it's very expensive not really
for everyone the reason we built it is
to prove the point that electric
vehicles can have amazing performance
and we now hold the record for being the
fastest electric vehicle as well as in
France in public arts track so and yeah
we couldn't have accomplished without
partners working with us but we also had
a lot of engineering innovation from our
side that we brought to it that's great
there are some questions they're more
like korea-based so Robert asked what do
you think a few characteristics you
believe a person needs now and in the
near future to be successful oh this is
a great question and I actually say this
to let you say that the people hi hi I
think you me the biggest skill you need
to have these days is curiosity
curiosity to learn and explore and
because you know the company I'm
building right we have 300 people
we have mechanical engineers we have
electrical engineers low voltage
electrical engineers people that
understand grid then high voltage
systems
we have battery chemists we have
operating system understand operating
system software applications data
scientists mission it's like a
university almost right and so and we
all sit together and everyone has to
work together so the biggest strength
that I look for when I hire people is
are you curious to learn because no
one's figured this out we're all
figuring this out and the other thing I
tell people is if you're coming from
another company I don't need your
experience
I want your knowledge I think is a
mistake people make especially if you
spent you know years working in another
company and you're coming to a startup
or you're coming to a new space people
want an experience to me means you do
what you've done before you're 10 your
tendency would be that I did this at BMW
I teach at 4 I want to do it again
typically that won't work because it's
that's not what we're trying to do and
so I tell people I want the knowledge
that you've gained from your previous
works but you have to think of complete
something completely different
so so curiosity the ability to learn the
ability to really work as a team and I
don't mean like that in a very clichéd
way everybody talks about teamwork at
the end of the day in a startup you have
to make tough decisions and so
somebody's opinions gonna get ruled over
and we have to go about the ability to
to be comfortable with ambiguity and
listen to another person's point of view
I think these are things that I look at
how do you interview for that like when
you get a new person in yeah so you know
what I actually hand-picked the first
hundred and fifty people in my company
and literally everybody from a lobby
ambassador to my VP of autonomous Drive
I mean I interviewed everyone and the
reason that was important to me is the
first hundred people hire the next
thousand people right and so you want to
set the bar high and you want to set a
certain expectation of what room you're
looking for from them and so I asked all
kinds of questions about what do you do
when you're not working how do you spend
how do you like to spend the time that
you relax do you relax are you always
working what are importantly I mean I
love cooking when I'm not working and I
mean why do I love cooking I never
follow a recipe by the way I don't know
I'm terrible at baking I'm I enjoy
cooking because baking you have to be
let's feed backward I love to experiment
so I ask people these shows are
questions and so that you know I think
gives you an insight about what makes
them tick you want people who have an
interesting non professional life yes
absolutely they say oh I watch
television that's okay okay actually we
we have something that we call do at my
company called team time one Wednesday
in a month we take two hours out of our
work time and we all get together and we
do some activity it could be some trivia
about cars trivia about technology
geography some project together and the
intent is that firstly it's okay to take
a break even though you're working like
incredibly hard and then secondly when
you take a break the idea is I don't
want people to just stay in their silo I
want them to go meet other people if
you're a software person go talk to the
mechanical engineer working on the car
trying to figure out what they're doing
so it sort of forces all us all to get
together related this question from
Vidya how do we trust when everything
ever in the industry in the industry and
new jobs are so new yeah that's another
great question you know Trust is a big
big thing you know and it's it's very
hard to say do you trust someone I don't
trust someone and I think sometimes we
oversimplify it perhaps overuse the word
Jimmy trust is something it is being
transparent how the way you build trust
right when things are ambiguous is being
transparent and being comfortable with
saying I don't know I have to go
research that or I have to go find that
out so in fact one of the things I asked
people in interviews is to test their
ability to say gee I don't know the
answer to that we're just trying to make
it out and if someone's trying to make
it up you know that they're insecure
with themselves and that breaks trust
right and so to me I look for
transparency and the way if you are
transparent and if you expect the other
person to be transparent you will trust
in an ambiguous environment
you obviously operate in Statesville
we have a partner company in China tell
us what the difference in the
marketplace are this is my regulations
footing are you bidding yeah yeah so in
the beginning when we started we
actually thought one team could build
products for both markets right you know
we started we the China team started
actually a year ahead of us and in
Silicon Valley and they were looking at
the China market solely the China market
and when we started we thought okay we
could take their platform their radical
platform add additional technology we
would be able to do that but we found
the markets are actually very very
different which way
so China you know I think the consumers
in Jennifer stevie's is the fastest
growing market for electric vehicles and
for cars in general you know I think a
lot of people in China now aspire to own
cars so the market is the fastest
growing anywhere in the world and the
government's actually forcing people to
shift from ICS to E which is a great
thing
consumers though how they interact with
technology is very different it's much
more icon based it's much more mobile
driven right you know we chart is huge
as a platform so you have to be able to
integrate with that platform there are
no garages for by and large in China
people don't have big homes like we knew
here so if you're building an electric
car you know here you have a Tesla saw
and I have one boy put it at the same
time too
but you know I charge my car at home or
at work right and so in China that's not
possible people don't have garages you
can't cut charge your car so how do you
give them the convenience of charging so
there's very different constraints that
you have to think about when you are
thinking about the vehicle platform so
the team we have in China or sister
companies really focused on that market
and that consumer and if you look at the
US the public problem we have is long
commutes on highways highway driving 136
million Americans commute 30 minutes or
so one way every day from work oh yeah
yeah and I'm one of them I commute 45
minutes one way to join I live in Palo
Alto I work in San Jose so that's you
know so we have different
the neighboring cities the distance is
not that much but the traffic is
terrible so the constraints are
different and the needs are different so
this is why we actually have two
different platforms now and we share
supply chain we share a lot of the
supplier ecosystem but the products are
different and I think this is one thing
by the way about the car that's
different from an iPhone or a smartphone
a car as a product
it matters who it lives with and where
it is living is it living with a family
of seven in Shanghai or New Delhi or
Mexico City or is it living with a
single guy in San Francisco the kind of
product needs are very very different
that's not the case with iPhone or
smartphone right it's sort of like very
different given what you said you still
don't believe that the future of cars
will be transportation to service like
right sharing I think the right sharing
you believe they're very strongly yeah I
think night sharing will absolutely grow
I don't think it will replace ownership
right in the example I use is just
because we have Airbnb doesn't mean
people don't buy homes still buy homes
we love living in that you know Jimmy
car is an extension of a personal space
and I think you know people leave stuff
in their car you realize I think in New
York City there's no more overrides and
ownership all right true but New York
City always people use the subways I
would argue that if you lived in
Manhattan you probably didn't own cars
even before uber you took cabs or
subways and that's true in San Francisco
probably true in Chicago you know major
cities but like I said majority of
people would love to live in a bigger
space outside of the city and drive to
work and I don't think that need will go
away another thing I feel like owning
mobility is sort of reflects us reflects
on us as owning freedom right I think
human beings equate mobility with
freedom for years we've been explorers
we always wanted to go places and
discover new places all that I think
will be the basic desires so if you have
an autonomous car you could it mean
effect make your own flight whenever you
want you can sleep
the car right so you actually don't have
a red eye anymore but you can travel at
night and sleep that's nice very nice
one last question for you if you had a
magic wand and could create any
technology what would you want to see
solved hmm okay you're gonna laugh but I
would do disposable clothing
biodegradable clothes I'm a fashion that
I love I love to be tall I love to be
fashionable but I hate buying so many
clothes that after a while get out of
fashion you've heard about this company
Renta one way I know I know but you're
still you know it's still things that
are not biodegradable so I would love to
have these things that are beautiful to
wear that you would wear and after that
they degrade biodegrade and then you get
something else important they degrade
after you animal but he also the ones
would you also want 3d printed clothing
them but do you say our tonight is the
yellow I think I think there's an
amazing opportunity to reinvent clothing
in my opinion and we have our wardrobes
full of all clothing it's just I know I
know yes and then you feel guilty then
you give them away and then you feel bad
you're giving outdated clothes to
somebody
yeah it's sort of like so much of that
will go away all right that my really
really great pleasure having her here
thanks I learn a lot from you and I hope
you students and viewers also learned a
lot it's been a great pleasure to run
the 8th now of our heat as he talks
organized by our very own chana's I'm
asked to remind all viewers that Udacity
intersect is coming up in March
please check our website and come attend
because you get to see amazing leaders
including Astro teller and I believe
it's one Fidel and many others I'd see
you all in March and for the next year's
talks please stay tuned we announced the
next speaker soon on our website thank
you thank you
you